hi i'm mia healey and i play shelby
goodkind hi i'm erina james and i play
tony chalifoux on the wilds and we are
here to read our first tweets for
buzzfeed
number one i want someone to look at me
the way shelby looks at tony
oh i'm sorry
i'm so cute sometimes i turn around and
you're just like
i know there was one scene in season two
when you were like oh look at that face
and it's like literally like
i know i'm not approaching i believe in
tony and shelby supremacy exactly ship
shoney for clan skills
hashtag
that is so cute tony and shelby yeah i
will pass out they're both so hot i'm at
my limit you guys
oh my days
gosh i'm like blushy tony shalfoe if you
read this i'm free on thursday night i
would like to hang out please let me
know if your free thursday night so you
can hang out with me on thursday night
when i'm free
that's going to be one of my favorite
ones
i know this i love the shallow flower so
direct just like tony sharp i'm speaking
directly to you
hey yeah
normal shelby is beautiful and then like
love heart eye emoji but bald shelby is
hot hashtag wilds
i feel hot when i'm shell-balled i'm
like damn i love that you've got an
energy about you when you're
shell-balled like you step out and like
on set
the head's so much bigger than what you
see on the show and it's all bald
there's no like hair in it it's just
like this is so good i already know
shelby is gonna call tony all sorts of
cute nicknames and i'm not ready i just
love them together just leave it at that
the scene where shelby kisses tony and
then i don't even know how to pronounce
this because you just it's like the
gibberish thing
i always write
that's like
it went from a hate argument to a
mind-blowing kiss wow that was hot and
intense keeping the best
you know just before the cliff kiss
where tony melts into shelby's hand dot
dot dot gay excellence we're just like
shelby's always holding tony's face have
you noticed that you know it's like
always like
yeah you just really are holding on so
tight it's adorable oh my gosh i died
shelby really fell in love with tony at
first sight and found every possible way
to touch her on that first date
that is so true if you think about if
you watch back to the first episode of
season one
did you realize that like she was like
all right when was she trying to get
everyone to like move around on the
plane like yeah go straight up to tony
she's like oh putting her hands on her
shoulders like come on
what's interesting though is that we
didn't even know in this in that episode
that shelby was even positive so that
was just lucky oh here we go again the
way shelby immediately holds tony's
cheek whenever they do anything internet
is so cute
oh my god no not this
so it's quote you my child is completely
fine end quote your child thinks bald
shelby is kind of hot
as tony is hot as hell and then she goes
and imitates shelby and i form even more
in love and help
when you're in the bunker yeah i say
like oh it'll just mix it up more that
way oh i don't know but i love that
little moment
so cute and i remember when i shot that
i was like because this is before our
journey together yeah i played like mad
and then they were like just try it for
a taste try it like
you're thinking
i was like okay
easter egg shelby with short hair as hot
as
i don't even give a [ __ ]
honestly again i felt so hot in that
haircut as well
maybe i should just cut off all my hair
clearly it works for me the way tony did
a full 180 turn from an angry lesbian
into a soft teenage mess once shelby
kissed her it really was a full 180
script so quick
throughout the script
she threw it out
okay sorry i'm reading it the way one of
shelby's first scenes was her smacking a
man's unwanted hand off her boob and one
of her last scenes was taking her off
woman after being asked if she was oh
sure is kind of iconic we love consent
and we love homosexuality and we love
tony and shelby wait that is so cute so
cute
tony's a whole change of demeanor when
she finally started to understand what
shelby was going through leading to more
of her character development is one of
my favorite things the wilds ever did
fought them a script on the expectations
leia's bae i will crumble into pieces if
there's one scene of shony cuddling and
whispering cute to each other at the
crack ass of dawn and fatten just
screams shut up we get it you're in love
yes
i just know shawnee's gonna be so gay
next season like i know for a fact that
me and erin won't let us down they're
definitely gonna give us some cute
little background moments
it's gonna be so cute and adorable
period
and i hope that you're not disappointed
yeah i hope you guys are disappointed
too
i love this these people so sweet that
was so gorgeous reading all the tweets
thank you buzzfeed for putting all this
together and make sure that you watch
the wild season 2 on video
[Music]
you